mind your decisions i'm presh tallwalker
a rectangle is divided into the
following eight squares
if the smallest square in the center has
a side length equal to one and an area
equal to one what is the area of the
entire rectangle
this question is adapted from one on the
2017 dutch mats olympiad
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so how can we solve this problem
to get started suppose the large square
has a side length equal to x
we are then going to maneuver around
this diagram like a maze and we're going
to get another expression for the side
length of this large square
that will allow us to solve for x then
we can solve for the side lengths of the
large rectangle and then we'll compute
its area so let's get started
we will first compute this length which
is the sum of the two side lengths of
these squares
it will be equal to one plus x
each square will have a side length
that's one half of that which will be
equal to one half plus x over two
let's now compute this distance
it'll be equal to the length of one of
these squares plus one
so it will be equal to three over two
plus x over two
now suppose this square has a side
length equal to a
the two squares above it have a total
length equal to a which means each of
them has a sine length equal to a over
two
therefore three over two multiplied by a
is equal to three over two plus x over
two
we can solve this equation for a to get
that a is equal to one plus x over three
we can then compute this
distance it'll be equal to a plus 1 so
it will be equal to 2 plus x over 3.
now again we want to compute the side
length of this large square we already
know it's equal to x but we also know
that it will be equal to the side length
of the top square plus one
so it's also equal to three plus x over
three
we can then solve this equation for x
we get two over three multiplied by x is
equal to three which means x is equal to
nine over two
from here we'll compute the side lengths
of the large rectangle
one side length will be equal to two
plus four over three x
and that is equal to eight
the other side length will be equal to
one half plus three over two multiplied
by x we can then substitute x is equal
to nine over two and we'll get that this
is equal to twenty-nine over 4.
we thus have these two side lengths and
thus we can compute the area of the
rectangle which will be equal to 8
multiplied by 29 over 4 and that's equal
to 58 and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
you